assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh to its ramadan we're fasting
and we want to take a break during this
blessed month and get some advice from a
gem here in Chicago he's been active in
the Dawa for almost 40 years salam
alayka shake slammer i'm told i work at
would have had like how are you ready
good alhamdulillah tell us now how is it
change since when you were coming up
about 40 years ago there was almost
probably like there was no mustard in
the city people you guys were like
praying in the closets or something well
just speaking of the closet if i
remember right back in 1972 we used to
pray juma and the staircases of a
building downtown sticky get staircases
staircase as a matter of fact it was the
company was Arzo how does the
engineering and then we had a place that
we rented down there on Adams Street and
when I remember I became a supervisor at
that time then I was able to reserve the
conference room in my company he works
for the company downtown and from there
on we had this place in on Adams Street
which is grew up and now later on we
built that building we bought the
building on State Street and you
actually one of the first books my uncle
dr. Kosovich she gave me a book called
life death in the hereafter by dr.
Yamazaki you knew him very well I know
yeah we were very close to each other
his kids grow up with my kids and and I
attended his janessa and in Los Angeles
recently and I visited him a couple
times before he passed away and I was
lucky because he still remember me at
that time yeah what what it what advice
I mean do you have I've been talking
about Muhammad Ali this week and
somebody like him who was an American
Muslim hero was not as scared of his
identity you know a lot of Muslims that
you end up changing their names you know
Fatima goes to Fozzie Muhammad goes to
mow scared of their identity and even
celebrities even more so because it's
not the cool
thing Muhammad Ali didn't care he was
out there given Dawa any chance he got
an incredible story was that he would
one of my first teachers you know i'm
also dr. amir Ali and I just had also on
the show from president of some vision
abdul malik Mujaahid there was telling
me the story that he would take is Jesus
God pamphlets he had like 500 of them in
an hour he would distribute because
people come and they want to get his
autograph and then he was in a no you
got to take it from here you know he'd
sign it and even I think a congressman
or senator still has one of those that
was talking at his janazah all he
attracted big big crowds that day in the
as he always did and eagerly gave
everyone autographed pamphlets
explaining his Muslim beliefs hundreds
of Mormons lined up to grab all these
pamphlets and of course I took one for
myself I respected his deeply held
convictions just to see respected mine
about this how how can we we can learn
from this you know you've been doing Dow
up for you know 40 years now how can we
motivate people to really take this
example and run with it in especially at
a time like this would you say it's a
golden opportunity it is today is the
the best opportunity for us and let me
share with you what happened to me
something that also changed my life in a
way back almost it's almost four years
ago I used to travel to the Middle East
quite a bit like 10 15 times a year and
since I'm from Egypt then I used to go
to through Cairo in and out and somebody
introduced me to a one message which is
called an assembly medic it's a suburb
of Cairo and the imam ahmed ali ibrahim
Ezard i used to attend the hood buzzer
and I used to cry he made me cry every
time I attend the hopper and my brother
we used to live on the other side of
town and it took us two hours to just
drive to the machine he said you crying
here I can beat you up in my mouth in my
house and we can go to the masala next
door but anyway in that magic which is a
huge magic I mean the measurement we are
and today is just a little tiny thing
compared to every Thursday of the year
they have a decaf people will stay all
my there
and the measured will be packed so one
time I stayed there and after fajr
prayer we will sit groups in a circle
and we didn't go on and we get to know
each other so one time Sheikh Ibrahim as
it came to the group where I was sitting
and to do introduction and ask everybody
their name and when it came to me he
said what's your name is at pfizer
hamuda he said where are you from he
meant which part of Cairo which part of
Egypt but the brother was sitting next
to me all night he said oh brother
pfizer her modem in Chicago from Chicago
Egypt a united states america so she's a
pre-measured grabbed me from my shirt is
it aunt America are you from America I
said yes he said are you from America I
said yes he said you are the messenger
of the messenger in America hungry and
he continued to say even have never been
in the United States he said America is
pregnant with Islam and needs a good
doctor to deliver the baby whatever he
has told me that I have been repeating
it and I've been teaching it to kids
everywhere and it really and truly when
you look at all around the world you
will find out the most and the closest
to Islam and a way of life and what have
you is America as a matter of fact we
and myself and few friends we having a
project which we will go through the
American Constitution and to bring where
it came from quran and sunnah and we
gotta call it the American Constitution
for real Islamic perspective believe it
or not people are talking about Sharia
negatively but the American Constitution
is the closest document in compliance
with the Sharia the Quran and the Sunnah
amazing can you give us some ones like
come on now someone you know maybe
they're not yet Muslim he's turning in
he's like look at these guys they
over-exaggerate I'm repair i'ma play the
skeptic and he's like come on show me
something give me an example well
freedom of speech is coming from Islam
freedom of owning things freedom of
working anywhere you want this has been
Islamic traditions and Islamic tenants a
person is innocent until proven guilty
this is coming from Islam straight from
Islam be nice your neighbor it's
Paracelsus alum Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him he's always advised us to be
nice to the neighbors how to think about
your country how to think about the
progress of humanity it's all coming
from Islam as a matter of fact I had my
doubts that the American Constitution is
parked somebody have peeked into the
Quran and now when you know that
President Jefferson had his own copy of
the Quran and you know that he have done
a lot of studies on the Quran and when
you see what's going on in the American
Constitution and the Bill of Rights you
see what it is even go back to the
British they have the Magna Carta the
Magna Carta which is how a community can
live together this is copied from what
prophet muhammad peace be upon him did
when he moved to medina over 1400 years
ago where their inhabitants were
non-believers and Jews and other
communities and he made this what they
call it the constitution of Medina which
is the call it now Magna Carta which is
how people can live together that
everybody is free to worship the way
they wanted but everybody is also are
responsible to chip in to defend the
community and to work toward developing
the community so this is the essence of
Islam is what's in the American
Constitution and hopefully soon we will
come up with these studies and show
every article of the Constitution where
it comes from one verse of the Quran or
more or one hadith a narration of the
responses Allah we're going to keep this
short we're not going to take up too
much of your time just a couple more
points doesn't Harvard University they
have a quote from the verbatim word of
god the qur'an miss the most prestigious
law school and they have the quran up
there and as it has if they have a verse
from the quran from Surat Annisa they
said this is the most is just and fair a
statement made by human beings and the
verse says that if you're going to judge
you have to judge fairly and squarely
even you are judging for your family
members or
poor or rich that is deep in one more we
got one more thing will close it up with
what am I looking at here what prophet
muhammad peace but can you what does
that say shake shown that yeah this is
the supreme court yeah the supreme court
they have the same thing the best man in
the world look at prov muhammad honored
by the supreme court of the USA as one
of the greatest law givers in the world
the muslims have been here even before
Columbus we've been here inviting people
the purpose to please get to know your
Muslim neighbor make the human
connection don't believe all the hype
what other advice you get you got for
the Muslims and they're not yet Muslims
the not your Muslims who are now many of
them are have fallen susceptible to the
radical elements out there they're
brainwashed and thinking that here's the
Muslim boogeyman coming to get you and
the Muslims who are not dynamic there's
stagnant they're not sharing the message
being with you said the messengers of
the messenger let me just put it in a
very short story and this is what
happened mcc brother who at his wife
would take care of the service cool they
go to costco every week to buy snacks
and one day they went home and they
found out they have more snacks than
they paid for at the amount of two
hundred dollars so went back to costco
and they talk to the customer service
and the customer service usually become
people complaining that they are short
changed and they kept telling them that
they are wrong there until finally the
lady there she found out yet they are
coming to bring back two hundred dollars
to us and she asked him what kind of
people are you they said we are Muslims
to make a long story short that lady in
the customer service I saw her wearing a
scarf attending Juma prayer at MCC one
day later so it's our behavior as
Muslims to stick to the teachings of
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him which
is we have to have the most and the best
morals and the most ethics values in the
world and most morals and ethics not
only to Muslims but to all human beings
at large not only to all human beings at
large but to own creatures around the
world as a matter of fact it's a story
that prophet muhammad saw Sam tell us
that
woman a bad woman that she was granted
to heaven because she gave water to a
thirsty dog so not only that we have
take care of human beings but they have
take care of all creatures and the way
we have it is showing our models we
don't lie we don't like to nobody we
don't steal we don't cheat we love
everybody and we care for everybody our
neighbors and humanity at large
beautiful thank you so much shake I
often say Islam is l am Aslam says love
o mankind as why we're here sharing this
message of peace and purpose with the
world subscribe if you haven't already
we'll see you next time inshallah God
willing until then peace be with you
Salaam alaikum